to your left because your season you
played so few games last year the fact
that you're now in the finals have been
part of this run does that individually
personally make that sweeter for you
yeah I mean the win the year I had last
year and then just be able to play in
the finals this year has been great but
you know I've been happy just being able
to return back to basketball you know to
begin it at a regular season and it's uh
you know pretty much something at home
you know I look back on of not being
able to play and now I'm able to play so
it's just like to me just enjoy us while
you're here because you never know when
you know those times will come you're
not gonna be able to play or you get
injured so that's what my mind said you
know really comes from and you know what
made me grow as a player because those
are the worst times and you know
basketball it's no losing games or you
know missing shots it's about you being
able to play or not on a floor you know
just so we grew up our whole lives to
our grew up my whole life wanting to do
is to play in NBA and you know when I've
taken away is terrible